there was this weird opportunity to do
something unprecedented really in the
history of nonfiction film to confront a
perpetrator while the perpetrator still
holds a monopoly on power is something
that's never been done before because
it's dangerous but we were able to do it
because of the film this is Joshua
Oppenheimer his two films are the most
frightening and moving I think I've ever
seen they're essentially a series of
confrontations with the perpetrators of
a horrifying chapter in Indonesia's
history though the village ill ability
to jihad and run it would wahdan or on
Yamaha Shia pommel and oh I almost began
developing in 1965 there was a
right-wing military coup the military
took over Indonesia with the help of the
United States and other Western
countries and within six months to a
year somewhere between half a million
and two and a half million people were
killed anyone who was seen is not likely
to just embrace the new dictatorship was
accused of being a communist and killed
first in the act of killing he confronts
people who carried out these killings
with essentially a mirror never really
held to account for their killings they
boast so Oppenheimer asked the
perpetrators to dramatize their actions
I said you you participated in one of
the biggest killings in human history I
want to know what it means to you into
your society you want to show me what
you've done so show me what you've done
in whatever way you wish I will film
your dramatizations and they're not
reenactments they're dramatizations
because reenactments are about what
happened in the past dramatizations are
actually acting out how they want to be
seen in the present the perpetrators
involved start to realize they will not
be seen as heroes cossack shashka the
beginning a villain
mini attack on vaudeville I'm getting a
flashback a young Lulu pega haga Jim
young young kabuki done Oppenheimer knew
that releasing the film would mean never
going back to Indonesia but it created
an opportunity I was perceived to be
close to the highest-ranking
perpetrators in the country before
release he orchestrated a second set of
even more direct confrontation
mmm then baba yaga but don't yell at us
Amano Han yung re the youngest son in a
family of survivors his oldest brother
was killed
oh man black tea yeah he feels trapped
in this kind of prison of fear that
comes as a survivor from living
surrounded by the still powerful
perpetrators and even I've been there
the wounded one he feels the need to go
to them in the hope that that he will be
able to make peace with his neighbors
Erina Rick I'm gonna get my boob Rafa
orang pompano III intelligent by marika
t da graça but um we uh we had to take
many safety precautions while shooting
including bringing a second car having
Audis family at the airport ready to
evacuate in case anything went wrong
adi would come with no ID no telephone
so they wouldn't be able to figure out
who he was until we were able to get
help Chaitanya idea about how I'd your
granny said you made me that
the good Rosa la cañada I got up the
Indonesian government perhaps in
response in part to the changes these
two films have helped to catalyze has
introduced a Truth and Reconciliation
bill in the parliament it'll be a
struggle though to get make sure that
bill has real teeth and is credible that
oligarchs in Indonesia the wealthiest
the most powerful will not want their
power and wealth exposed as the fruits
of plunder and atrocity but there's
another perpetrator confronted to
there's a moment in the look of silence
where a perpetrator looks straight at me
because he knows I'm American and says
we killed because the Americans told us
to kill the continent the Americans
taught us to hate the Communists and
then there's a long pause while he looks
at the camera and of course he's looking
at me
but because just as in this interview
I'm looking at the camera and at the
audience he's also looking at the
audience and for an American audience
it's a direct implication the details
that have come to the surface are
damning I mean to have an embassy
official who's compiling lists of
thousands of names of people asking that
they be killed its directly implicating
all of us in the film is a mirror in
which we hopefully see ourselves
you